hi there today we're looking at high
performance large-scale
image recognition without normalization
by andrew brock
silham day samuel l smith and karen
simonian of deepmind this is otherwise
known as
nf nets normalizer free networks
so the point of this paper is to build
networks
in this case specifically convolutional
residual
style networks that have no
batch normalization built in and we'll
get to why
in you know during looking at this paper
but without the batch normalization
usually
these networks are performing not as
well
or cannot scale to larger batch sizes
however
this paper right here builds networks
that can scale to large batch sizes
and are more efficient than
previous state-of-the-art methods so if
you compare them to
something like an efficient net and i
called it i called it you shouldn't call
your model
efficientnet because a more efficient
model is going to come around
so nfnet are now officially efficient or
net
okay as you can see right here to reach
the same accuracy as an efficient at b7
you need i think they say they have an
over
8.7 x speed up if you look at the
training
latency and that's going to be important
while looking at these experiments in a
second
and if you train for as long as the
efficient at b7
you can reach a higher performance this
is imagenet top one accuracy
and this model is a new state of the art
without additional training data and it
is also a new state-of-the-art
transfer learning and it is the
currently ranked
number two behind a method that uses
semi-supervised pre-training with extra
data so in the kind of global leader
board it's number two but it is
number one in various categories
uh imagenet has now become you know like
speed running there is there's
glitch-less and the equivalent is like
additional training data less
and so on in any case we'll go through
the paper
um we'll discuss what the tricks are to
get the normalizer free networks
to work i do have also a fair bit of
let's say criticism um
against this paper right here but in
general uh it's a pretty cool paper the
code is available i'll
of course link to the code uh you can
try it out yourselves and that's
you know it's pretty cool that the code
is available all right
if you like content like this as always
don't hesitate to share it out consider
subscribing
let's dive in what's the problem with
batch norm
batch norm as you might know i've done a
video on
batch norm but essentially what it says
is that if you have
a data point that goes through a network
you know it will experience various
transformations as it goes down the
layers
however some of these transformations
are
quite unfortunate if you build the
network
a little bit in a wrong way so
what might happen is that your initial
data distribution
might be you know in machine learning
it's good practice to center the data
and around the mean and kind of you know
scale it
to unit variants or something like this
but then as you progress through the
layers and especially if you have
something like
relu layers they only extract the
positive part
of the signal so with time it can happen
that the intermediate representation
right here
for example is you know something like
this
so it's very skewed it's not centered
and so on and
the the current methods we have in
machine learning they just work better
if your data is sort of well behaved has
a nice condition number
is centered and so on so what batch norm
does is every layer
it comes in it looks at the current
batch of data the current mini batch
and it centers and re-scales it
so what it would do is it would
transform this data
by a simple standardization procedure
into a well-behaved data set
of course remembering the transformation
for a back prop
and then feeding that data to the next
layer
that's batch norm and it has several
disadvantages
so the disadvantages of batch norm this
paper identifies
three batch normalization has three
significant
practical disadvantages first
it is a surprisingly expensive
computational primitive
which incurs memory overhead okay which
is
you know you need to compute these means
and these
scalings and you need to remember them
for
the back prop all right
second of all sorry significantly
increases the time required to evaluate
the gradient
in some networks i mean there is yeah
there is
some back prop you have to do through
all of this standardization
second it introduces a discrepancy
between
the behavior of the model during
training and
at inference time which is also true
because at inference time you don't want
this kind of batch dependence you want
to be able to feed a single data point
and the result should always be the same
irrespective of the other data and
people usually do this
by so at training time you simply
calculate this
mean shift right here and the scaling
that you have to do
and what you would do is you'd have kind
of a database a special buffer where
you save these things for every batch
and then at
test time you simply look at your buffer
you kind of build a
mean a moving average over your training
data
and you'll simply use those shifts and
variants so you have a discrepancy
between training data which just looks
at the current batch
and inference which looks at your
mean your average over the last few
batches
and third of all and this is the so this
introduces
hidden hyper parameters that have to be
tuned
which is kind of how fast the mean
decays in your database
and third most importantly so most
importantly
batch normalization breaks the
independence between
training examples in the mini batch okay
so
not you it now matters which other
examples
are in the batch and that has two
consequences so
the first consequence is that
batch size matters so batch size matters
in batch normalization if you have a
large batch you can compute these means
of the data they are a much better
approximation to the true mean
of the current data set at this
particular representation
than a small batch so if you just have
three examples the mean is going to be a
very noisy approximation
whereas if you have a large batch it's a
good approximation so batch size matters
for batch norm and second of all so
distributed training is distributed
training
yeah yeah yeah distributed training
becomes
extremely cumbersome because if you
do for example data parallelism which
means that here you have your
batch of data and we know for some
applications that
large batches are pretty favorable for
training they stabilize
training you can do uh larger step sizes
and so on
so what people do is they split the
batch they
shard one batch into let's say
three different parts and they have the
network on three different machines so
the same network
is on three different machines and what
you would like to do
is you would like to forward propagate
all of these batches through the network
sorry this whole batch in three
different shards
through the network and then back
propagate and sort of communicate the
gradients around but now imagine if you
have a batch norm layer
so if you have a batch norm layer right
here it's going to be the same here
and it's going to be the same here what
you would have to do technically
is you have to forward propagate the
signal right here
to the batch norm layer and then you'd
have to communicate
these batch statistics between the batch
normal layers
because otherwise you don't have the
mean and the variance over your whole
batch that you feed in right you can opt
to not
do this computation but then again you
run into the problem that
usually these the number of samples in
the shard
is fairly small and you have a bad
approximation so
batch norm just kind of makes certain
things
complicated right and this
interdependence of training data points
is
one of those things and they call it the
most important
things so they say this third property
has neg
a range of negative consequences
practitioners have found that batch
normalized networks often
difficult to replicate precisely on
different hardware
batch normalization the cause of subtle
implementation errors
okay well yeah especially during
distributed
training and then it cannot be used for
some tasks since the interaction between
training examples in a batch enables the
network to cheat
certain loss functions so this is let's
say you have a like a time series
prediction
right and in a time series prediction so
you have your your
time series and you want to make
training samples of it
so what you usually do is you say well
this is my input
and this is my goal and
then and this is my input and this is my
goal so it's kind of it's like language
modeling if you do that
so you want to slice one sequence into
many training samples so you do like
overlapping training
samples so like this is the input and
this is the goal
now imagine you have those two things in
the same
batch then technically
the this training sample here could just
kind of by means of the batch statistic
aggregation information can actually
flow because this here
technically is part of the input of one
training data point but it's the label
for the other training data point
so there can be information leakage in
that
so you shouldn't use batch norm or
anything that
connects the training samples to each
other in these particular cases it's
kind of an edge case
and you can you can probably get around
it by just
having a big data set and shuffling um
a lot but still so
um they say they solve all of these
things
specifically they say we propose
adaptive gradient clipping which clips
gradients based on their unit-wise
ratio of gradient norms to parameter
norms and we demonstrate that agc
allows us to train normalizer-free
networks with larger batch sizes and
stronger data augmentations
so their method of um
of circumventing batch norm of building
networks that don't have batch norm
anymore
is going to be this adaptive gradient
clipping
it's going to be in combination with
earlier work from an earlier paper
that they've done and but this paper
introduces specifically
that adaptive gradient clipping you're
going to see it's a pretty simple idea
it should be implementable in pretty
much any network out there
and it has a potential to become kind of
a staple
component in deep learning if it turns
out to
actually work as well as they say in the
paper
they say we design a family of
normalizer-free resnets called
nfnets which set the new
state-of-the-art validation accuracies
on imagenet for a range of training
latencies
okay so they repeat these things from
what i said in the intro
and they also say achieve substantially
higher validation accuracy than batch
normalized networks when fine tuning on
imagenet
after pre-training so they also have a
good transfer accuracy
now my first problem with this is that
the two things here
are kind of not
very related so the gradient clipping is
an actual let's say a contribution it's
a new
method they it they measure it
absolutely cool
but then they go around and they do like
giant
architecture searches for how could we
replace the convnet block and so on
to come up with these nf nets which
is also cool but it is not
clear to me that these two things are
necessarily as connected as they make it
to be of course they would say well
since it's normalizer free we can build
some but i don't see why you couldn't
just do
like better architecture search for
classic batch norms networks so it seems
like
and then you don't you don't know where
the gains actually come from like
whether or not you need the gradient
clipping or whether the contribution
here is actually to figure out a kind of
a better
resnet architecture you know who
who knows in any case they the
structure of the papers that follows
they first go what does batch norm do
what does it do well and then how can we
replace
all of the things that it does well by
our own stuff and then not need batch
norm anymore so they
identify four things batch normalization
down
scales the residual branch so in a
resnet you usually have an input
and then you put that through a series
of layers
to the output but first you add the
input again so you add the two
and this and this is so this part is
called the residual
branch it's kind of so this is the
identity function i've done a video on
resnets
if you want to learn more about that on
residual networks
and batch norm will down scale the
residual
branch implicitly and
that just means that the signal strength
is
more in favor of this identity function
which is the entire point of resnets
which makes training more
stable second batch normalization
eliminates mean shift and that's the
thing
we said before that for example if you
have
relus or something like this they only
retain the positive part of the signal
which
leads down the network to quite a shift
in the mean of the data
and batch norm eliminates that third
batch normalization has a regularizing
effect
by means of the the batch statistics are
noisy
which you know we said is a problem for
inference yes but it is also has a
regularizing effect during training
and lastly batch normalization allows
efficient
large batch training so it smoothens the
lost landscape
and this increases the largest stable
learning
rate okay so we want to get
we want to get to a point where we get
all these benefits but don't need batch
norm anymore
so first they introduce their old paper
and their old paper it's not that old i
think it's so it is this one here you
can see it's also this here
it's an it's it's an iclear paper
and there they built these normalizer
free
resnets these nf resonance not to be
confused with
nf nets which this paper introduces okay
so the normalizer-free resnets
already try to build normalizer-free
resnets
they manage they manage to
build you know networks that train but
they don't beat the efficient net
efficiency yet what they do
specifically is they just pay attention
a lot to scaling so they introduce for
example these parameters
alpha and beta and what they do
is as essentially in every single block
in the neural network they try to
very carefully predict how this block
will change the variance
of the data and then they build
constants here so this is
is this alpha is this beta i think this
is alpha goes after
and beta goes before they build
constants alpha and beta these are
constants
that are made particularly for the
architecture so
if this is like a convlayer
they pay attention and they make these
constants such that the variance
kind of stays constant as you go down
the network so it's
very much like people build deep
learning frameworks where
you know for every operation you have to
define a gradient and then you can chain
them together
here for every block they you know
carefully think about how it affects the
variance of a signal
and then they design appropriate
scalings to bring that variance
back and if you do that consistently and
it's it is quite hard
right and they have to do a lot of
things for example also kind of a
a variant of weight standardization and
so on but
if you do this then you can
train quite large batch sizes so
normalizer-free resnets match the test
set accuracies achieved by batch
normalized pre-activation resnets on
imagenet
a batch size 124. they also
significantly outperform their batch
normalized counterparts when the batch
size is very small
but they perform worse than batch
normalized networks for large batch
sizes
crucially they do not match the
performance of state-of-the-art networks
like efficient nets and this paper is
going to fix
this all right the main way
um or one way the thing the paper
introduces
is this adaptive gradient clipping now
what is gradient clipping
so usually usually right you have a
parameter
it sits here in the parameter space and
then you get a gradient and you follow
that gradient you go like
over here down here over here down here
during
training now sometimes sometimes you
have
a batch of data that just tells it to
make a huge jump and this
these huge jumps are often the cause for
training instability
uh because for example if you use sgd
with momentum that thing will get into
your momentum
term and just skew the training over
here it will screw with your atom
buffers and even plain sgd
it's not really good if you take giant
jumps
so gradient clipping simply says
whenever a gradient
of any parameter is larger than a size
let's say
this size here we'll simply
clip it that's will scale it so that's
the maximum length
so if it is if it is you know if it's a
good gradient
you know we're surely going to see it
again but if it's a bad gradient
we want to limit its impact the problem
is that it's very sensitive to this
parameter right here
and the reason is it's not adaptive so
what do they mean by adaptive
what they do is the following it's
almost the same
so as you can see g is the gradient so
this
part right here is the same you want to
scale the gradient but you
want to not only clip the gradient
to its own norm but you want to clip the
gradient to the ratio
to this ratio right here so the ratio is
going to be
how large the gradient is versus how
large the weight
that the gradient acts upon is so
if you have a small weight
um if you have like a small weight and
you suggest a small change to it
fine but if you suggest a big change to
the weight
then it's like i'd rather sorry i
probably should draw this
like this so small change fine large
change
not so fine however if you already start
with a large weight
then you know large changes might be
appropriate because that's the general
scale
of that weight it is though it is an
approximation right it is not
it is not a um
it is not the end all it's simply a good
heuristic because you can make
cases where just comparing these norms
don't mean
everything so if your weight is this
and you have kind of a gradient that's
really large
that goes into this direction you know
that might be bad because
you kind of scale the gradient by a
factor of 3
right here but if i take the same length
gradient and just put it
into the other direction you've not
scaled the weight at all basically but
it's the same
length of gradient so just looking at
norms isn't
everything but it seems to be a good
heuristic and
with that heuristic a lot of the
problems of batch norms
fall away
so they do ablations right here where
you can see
that for example if you
compare batch norm networks
the normalizer free resonance from the
last paper and the normalizer free
resnet
plus this adaptive gradient clipping you
can see
that after a certain batch size the
non-agc network simply collapses while
the
ones while the batch norm one and the
gradient clipping one prevail so this
seems to be the recipe
to go to higher batch sizes pretty
pretty cool
but over here you can see
here is a different thing here it's top
one accuracy
versus clipping threshold so where where
do you
set of course there is still this
parameter here
and they complain that it's very finicky
with the
if you don't do adaptive gradient
clipping so i expect this to not
be as crucial if you do non-adaptive
gradient grading clipping
however here you can see that it has a
crucial dependence on
the batch size of all things so you can
see at small batch sizes
you can get away with clipping at a
pretty large threshold
but then at large batch sizes you can
see
you have to you have to keep the
threshold pretty low because
if you clip it higher then it's
you know it collapses now i was
told that one of the problems with batch
norm is this dependence
of training data points among like to
each other
and i kind of expected this paper to fix
it but
it doesn't in a very subtle way so here
is how
here is how the gradient clipping works
i i told you right here
if the gradient's too large we're going
to clip it right
pretty simple if it's too large you know
just clip it down
but what is a gradient a gradient is
actually composed
of the batch of data that you feed
through right
so you feed a batch of data through a
network
and then you have a weight somewhere
here and
the gradient that you get for the weight
so maybe the weight is here in weight
space the gradient
you get for the weight is an a sum
so your gradient for your weight of f
of x is going to be so this is a large x
this is all the data is going to be a
sum over your data points of the
gradient
you know with respect to that because
your loss
sorry this is a loss function
that your loss is a sum so
your gradient is the gradient of a sum
of loss functions
and these are interchangeable don't come
at me math people
not always but in this case i guess uh
so i hope you can you can sort of see
that your gradient is going to be a sum
over data points or a mean
over data points and that means that
it's not actually one gradient this one
gradient is made up
by many many data points pulling
that weight in different directions and
the gradient you end up with is simply
the average
over or the sum over all these gradients
that the individual
weights put it so if you now think
is in terms of gradient clipping and you
think
that during the data data
feeding process during the training
process every data point
is an sort of an estimate of the whole
data set
and that means that your gradient is
going to be noisy that's the point of
sgd
what happens to noise if you average it
over a bunch of iid samples it gets
smaller in relation to the signal right
if you have
if you input the whole data set you have
no noise you have a
perfect gradient at least over your
training data
as you make the batch smaller and
smaller you have more noise
so if you clip on the final gradient
as opposed to the individual data points
and i've checked in the code they first
do
the sum or the average then they do the
clipping
if you do that that means now the effect
of the clipping
is going to be dependent on the batch
size
and it means that you implicitly
interconnect your training data because
if you have a noisy process
right so if this is your this is your
base noisy process
and you average you'd always sample two
things
from that from the noisy process it has
this much noise
you're going to get something that has
less noise because it's the average of
two things
now if you average over a thousand
samples you're going to get something
that has very little noise right every
now and then
it has a bit of noise okay what you want
to do with the gradient clipping is you
want to
limit the impact of bad training data
points
training data points that just tell you
to go a lot into a
bad direction what does that mean if
i have one bad training data point in my
batch of four
that is going to spike the gradient a
lot like
right here so my gradient clipping
can be pretty high if i want to clip if
i want to limit the impact of that bad
data point
if i have a bad data point my gradient
is going to spike pretty heavily
and therefore my clipping threshold
should be high
however if i have one bad training data
pointing 1024
it's only going to spike the total
gradient a little bit
and therefore in order to filter out my
bat
training data points i need that
threshold at a much lower
level right and therefore i'm going to
you know filter out that one here now
so that's what i mean it makes the
training data points implicitly
dependent
on the others in the batch as batch norm
does it just doesn't do it
explicitly but still
there is a dependence on the batch which
i guess you could solve by doing the
clipping before you do the averaging but
it's not as easily implemented in the
frameworks that we have
by the way if you do and if that gets
you a better network cite the channel
um yeah on the way to become the first
cited youtube channel in a machine
learning research paper
i could be wrong though i mean i've
looked at the code i could it could be
that they do it before
i don't know okay so that's the deal
with
clipping and my issues with the fact
that this does still depend on the batch
so we haven't we haven't so actually
solved the dependence on the batch yet
we have probably solved the
computational issue they say you know
for calculating batch norm it takes a
while and it takes lots of compute
this here it doesn't it it still needs
compute
however probably not that much since you
can still you can just do it during the
backward
phase right you don't need anything
during the forward phase
for doing this clipping you simply
during the backward phase you need to
normalize
clip and you're good so we can take that
one
and then my third criticism right here
is that they say the third
or the second criticism on batch norm is
that
it has different train time behavior
as test time behavior which we discussed
which is true
but then what does their network contain
dropout dropout what's the property of
dropout
it has a different behavior a train and
a test time
like so you know don't
it's it's okay we get that batch norm
has these limitations
but your paper doesn't necessarily make
them better
it just kind of shifts them to different
to different things
okay enough rant so the second part of
the paper
goes into architecture building
so i actually don't want to touch this
as much but what they do
is they say well now we go about
building
a beast architecture that just
outperforms everything else
and i'm not sure what it has to do with
normalizer free networks like
this is something you can do with or
without batch norm
but they come up with this new
architecture
right here this new block let me scroll
to the end these new two blocks for
resnets
so the right one is where you do not
have a
kind of a down or up sampling and this
one is where you do
but you know they have done a lot of
search and you can see here are the beta
and alpha parameters to make this
normalizer free but
you know doing architecture search you
can do that
by yourself like you don't need the
normal maybe you need the normalizer
free but they don't make it
clear that these two things are so
intimately connected
and then they get the model they get up
here
and you know there is quite a bit of
evidence in the paper
that oh sorry this one there's quite a
bit of evidence in the paper that this
adaptive gradient clipping actually has
some nice properties yeah it allows you
to go
larger larger batch size and so on but
again it's it's a bit unclear what gains
come
from the normalizer free what gains come
from the
adaptive gradient clipping and what
gains simply come from the fact that
they have better architectures so their
whole point in architecture search is
that
efficiency net what it tries to do is it
tries to achieve an accuracy with as
little
as as little flops as possible
however modern accelerators cannot
necessarily make use
of those you know savings in flops
uh because you know they have certain
constraints and therefore
this network right here it focuses
explicitly
on training latency which means that if
you use current hardware which means
gpus or tpus
how fast is training so for a given time
of training
how much accuracy do you get and there
since it's particularly built for that
as you can see it beats efficient net by
a lot
however if you look at this in terms of
flops
um they have a demographic down here
so if you look at this in terms of flops
versus accuracy
as you can see it aligns with efficient
net
so the the kind of line here is pretty
as you can see like it's pretty straight
it's it's as if you were to scale up
the efficient net architecture for a bit
more
in terms of flop so this is better in
terms of so this is more optimized
for current hardware this kind of of
networks
yeah so that is pretty much it they do
do a lot of ablations comparisons and
it's not like i don't believe that the
adaptive gradient clipping
is it you know does nothing or that
you know clearly they also they always
do experiments they compare
the normalizer-free resnets with the
bachelor on resnet so they try to
isolate
the individual parts still i'm
i'm not sure how i feel about papers
that have you know
a lot of different things in one paper
and then they get state of the art you
never
exactly know why that is and the last
thing i want to mention
that's cool about this paper is appendix
e appendix e
i'll show you that appendix e is
negative results and this is really cool
so here is a list
of all the stuff they tried that didn't
work
and you know it's one page but still it
is
very very good even if it's only
to see that other researchers try a
whole lot of stuff
and fail as well so
i invite you to check out the paper i've
linked the code you can take the code
it's in
jax which is pretty cool by itself and
with that that was it for me bye bye